rando pays vous propose cette semaine de
découvrir une partie du cirque de ma
fate à travers le sentier qui relie
Marla à la nouvelle avec un détour par
la plaine au sable
pour votre santé parcourez nos sentiers
nicher au fond de ma fate à la plomb du
Grand Bénard Marla est l'un des Ilettes
les plus visités du cirque facilement
accessible depuis le col des Boeufs ou
le tahibit est constitue souvent le but
d'une excursion ou une étape de la
traversée des cirques
positionnez sur un plateau peu accidenté
et étendu l'illette est constituée de
cases espacées et de grandes zones
herbeuses qui favorisent une sensation
de calme et d'espace propice au bivouac
mais attention le principe du bivouac
c'est bien de ne laisser aucune trace
tiens bah voilà un exemple
d'un foyer fréquent c'est un endroit qui
est très utilisé par les randonneurs les
gens pensent que c'est autorisé c'est
vrai que l'endroit était
idyllique et une rivière il y a un petit
endroit gazonné c'est super pour faire
un bivouac donc le bivouac est toléré il
y a pas de problème les gens peuvent
bivouacer pas camper bivouaché mais par
contre ça le feu c'est vraiment très
très problématique il y a un gros risque
d'incendie qui est vraiment présent et
puis en plus derrière tout ça vous avez
des personnes qui sont malveillantes et
qui vont carrément laisser leurs déchets
alors aujourd'hui il y en a peu mais il
y en a pratiquement tous les jours des
fois c'est des boîtes de conserve c'est
des sacs plastiques enfin voilà c'est
c'est assez énorme
à la sortie de l'illette avant d'arriver
à maison Laclos un premier centime ils
furent qu'en direction de la nouvelle
choisir cette option permet de continuer
à longer la ravine de Marla sur un
sentier doux et peu accidenté
une descente facile conduit jusqu'au
fond de la ravine et la traversée de la
rivière
débloque rocheux à la taille imposante
et des résidus de brèche témoignent de
l'érosion à l'oeuvre sur notre île les
eaux de pluie et de ruissellement
construisent et façonnent en permanence
le paysage
là tu as l'exemple vraiment flagrant et
très visible d'un cas d'érosion très
rapide là c'est une zone où il y a
énormément d'éboulis et d'érosion
d'ailleurs on voit très bien le sentier
qui arrivait là-bas avant qui a dû être
détourné lors des dernières grosses
crues pour pouvoir passer par ici sinon
le passage n'était plus possible parce
que dès que ça commence à à couler un
peu fort ça ravine ça ça Hérode et ça ça
creuse se sentir a été fermé pendant
plusieurs jours voire plusieurs semaines
et le temps que les agents de l'ONF
puissent intervenir et sécuriser le
passage c'est et après ça a été réouvert
il y a vraiment beaucoup de mouvements
de terrain beaucoup d'érosion et à
l'échelle d'une vie on voit des
changements très rapides
après cette bifurcation qui matérialise
une autre option possible pour venir de
Marla c'est une traversée tranquille
dans les sous-bois de filao
au col de choix d'itinéraires sont
possibles restez à flanc de falaise et
ne pas perdre de dénivelé ou descendre
vers la plaine au sable un petit détour
en aller-retour qui permet d'aller jeter
un œil à cette véritable curiosité
naturelle de ma fate
au cœur d'un cirque aussi accidenté
rares sont en effet les espaces plats et
celui-ci est de loin le plus grand
ancien espace cultivé le manque d'eau
n'a pas permis d'y maintenir une
activité agricole aujourd'hui seule une
cabane abandonnée témoigne encore de ce
passé comme plus loin ces quelques
vaches qui ne sont plus réellement
exploitées
une montée raide mais rapide permet de
rejoindre le col au-dessus de la
dernière ravine avant la nouvelle
à l'approche de l'illette le plus peuplé
de ma fate le sentier reste large et
bien entretenu très facilement
accessible depuis le col des Boeufs il
est de la nouvelle et le plus dynamique
et le plus touristique du cirque un
projet de route depuis le col des vœux a
même été envisagé au début des années 90
mais a été rapidement abandonné pour
préserver le charme de ma fête comme à
Marla il était installé sur un plateau
large et étendu de nombreux commerces
snack Égypte permettent de s'y restaurer
ou d'Isser journée
ce que je trouve sympa sur cette sur
cette portion en fait c'est le côté
vallonné le côté pas très difficile de
la rando donc ça monte ça descend on a
le temps de se détendre un petit peu les
muscles et puis il y a plusieurs
traversées de cours d'eau qui sont très
sympas ou éventuellement on peut même se
rafraîchir un petit peu le visage en
s'arrêtant donc c'est agréable que
randonneur qui va qui va choisir de
faire un stop à Marla et un stop à la
nouvelle ou un stop à la nouvelle et un
stop à Marla ce sera donc à un
randonneur qui aura fait le choix de
faire une balade découverte tranquille
ce sera pas une grosse balade sportive
pour pour un gros niveau de randonneurs
mais en contrepartie ils vont pouvoir
avoir une variété de paysages assez
importante
sur un sur une distance pas très longue
et découvrir deux Ilettes qui sont
proches mais très différents